let's make you a rendering pro  how am i going to do that well let me  break it down for you twin motion has  been on the market for a while now and  many people are using it for the base  purpose it was originally intended for  lackluster amateur renders when used  correctly from start to finish you can  compete with the best without having a  dedicated rendering machine a team of 50  or even a good design let's look at an  example these two images are from the  same program one is a basic export the  other is carefully crafted designed to  stimulate your senses and intrigue you  most people either don't know where to  start are too lazy to start or is simply  not confident in their abilities let me  teach you the skills right here right  now